[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in the uh hall of famer
johnny bench who uh
went toe to toe i'm sure with hank quite
a few times and uh
i don't know when you got the news uh
johnny but uh if i'm bringing it to you
now i apologize but uh
i thought you'd be a good person to to
have on
well actually daniel i i got all of a
sudden a flood of
text and henry and with
you know eyes that are crying and i it's
and i said no
don't tell me this i mean i i'm just
absolutely worn out from
this is our ninth person in the years
and within the years time and
you know with don sutton and and los
sorta and i mean
uh don i used to hang out with in palm
springs and then i thought man this is
just getting too much and then
and i just sent a picture to fritzy and
i hope he can pull it up it's
hank sliding into me and it's hanging on
my wall here in my office
and henry said henry writes on it
to john i wish the hell you'd stay out
of my way
go ahead were you behind the plate when
hank hit 714 off jack billingham
yeah jack still says i called it wrong
wait what did you call fastball the
breaking ball a breaking ball and
and i was there at the i was standing on
home plate when i shook hank aaron's
hand too
because i dan when i when i broke in
uh and i'm catching and henry would come
up and you know i'd take all three put
his bat down he put his helmet on over
his soft cap
and he would say hi john how you doing
and nobody ever knew that
and from the very beginning i don't
think there was a game that when the
led off or when his first time at bat
that he didn't say hello
and i mean it was such a reward just to
be with the man and to be at the hall of
fame with him and his gentleness
his class at the gold glove awards i
mean just
anywhere you were with hank and
uh we were trying to put together a zoom
call just recently and it hasn't
happened and i'm
i'm so just sad and disappointed i mean
you can't
you know you can't measure the what
we've lost in baseball this year and
but he was just you know like i heard
you talking about the flip of the wrist
and everything else and
of course he filled out i mean his
forearms looked like my thighs i mean
they were you know you wonder how the
wrist and those forearms and everything
else and
hit off his front foot and just flicked
it and i mean it was
and you know 755 home runs if you take
those away he still had 3 000 hits
yeah yeah i mean this but it
you know but he was a great base dealer
he was a great defender
and he was just a better better man had
a better person i mean i
am i'm just so sad and uh
golly it's just and we can't do enough
you know to say for him and what he did
for baseball and
what he meant to baseball what he meant
to everybody he played with i can tell
you
to a man all those all those players
were just with adolation and
and respect and i don't think you're
going to leave a better legacy than
than for us to talk about him in this
kind of manner and say what a
what a just a gentle person and what a
wonderful person
and the all-time home run king to most
people yeah i wondered about that johnny
do you think
uh the hall of famers view hank as the
old-time home run king
yeah yeah and i i think it's just out of
respect and everything else i think of
everybody's always
always looking at the uh you know the
peds and the starry steroid era and
whatever and how much difference it
would have made and
you know and uh um it
i i you know it's sort of
but there there's there's so many
there's just few people in your life
that when you walk in
to the hall of fame and you walk in
where you walk into the hotel
and you know first time was ted williams
and there was joking there was
campanella and here's duke snyder and
you know here's
all these guys and that and uh and
there's henry and willie and i mean it
was just
it just gave credence it gave validity
to being in the hall of fame
i don't i don't know that we will ever
you know none of us will you know ever
have that stature i think
because it to me it will always be
that's what the hall of fame is it's
it's those people it's
you know what we dreamed of all our
lives and hitting in the rocks out of
the driveway
and and hitting playing home run derby
at the park and
you know and you know the thing is
if you think about it dan i don't know
that there's anybody that's ever
emulated hitting like hank aaron
because i don't think it's i don't think
you can i don't think you can
copy or emulate or perfect
those things he was one of a kind
as a as a baseball player and he's
one-of-a-kind as a person
and my whole being is sad
yeah we lost tom seaver we lost lou
brock we lost joe morgan
bob gibson don sutton now hank aaron
yeah listen and negro and sort necro i
i i talked to him and he was gone i
talked to him about once a week and
he uh i i don't know but i tell you a
story about
sparky calling me into the office one
day and
and he said john we've got a chance to
trade for negro
what do you think and i said you better
trade for his catcher
and he always loved that nux he was i
said you know he'd call me and i see you
tell me a joke or i don't want to talk
to you and of course
that was the one thing and analyst sort
of was just the wizard on my baseball
bunch and
uh i got to put you in bubble wrap all
right i got to make sure nothing
happens to you yeah i'm you know and all
of a sudden we start
feeling so vulnerable i mean it's like i
mean all of us i guess
you know to think that we're you know
there and that you know i talked to
raleigh i talked to wade boggs i talked
to
to brett and talk to robin yount the
other day and
you know you just want to call and you
know say just hey is this thinking about
you
get on that zoom call get on that zoom
call with these guys who are still alive
johnny yeah make sure you do it make
sure you do it hey
uh thank you buddy i appreciate it
that's uh johnny bench
and uh yeah i appreciate him coming on i
could hear it in his voice